[Music]
[Applause]
it's bringing Nick Wright co-host of
first things first on Fox Sports 1 and
subscribe to what's right with Nick
Wright on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcast what are you hot on today
Hi how are you thank you for the podcast
and YouTube show plug along with the you
know surging television show I
appreciate that uh you know I'd love to
talk NBA Finals with you I heard what
you were saying about jokic I the I it
was I agree with Paulie jokic did used
to be out of shape he no longer is uh
he's still incredibly unathletic but
that you know there are things I keep
hearing for example how untalented the
Miami Heat are
that may or may not be true but if it is
true it means we overvalue Talent or we
misevaluate talent because what the
Miami Heat do is find a way to win that
did you know the Heat lead the NBA and
play off victories over the last four
years think about that the Miami Heat
with Jimmy Butler and Fringe All-Star
bam out of bio and then on a similar
note jokic he's obviously unathletic but
he has solved offense as much as a
player can solve it and I guess we're
splitting hairs the most dominant
offensive player stepher jokic but it's
clearly one of the two of them who would
you side with there
historically obviously Steph right now
in the moment it's jokic right now
listen and I had been a jokic call it
critic or skeptic any of those things
but my biggest complaint was we were not
making him go through the steps we made
everyone else go through before they
were anointed the best player in the
league and multiple MVPs damn near three
straight MVPs the rules have always been
we you can get to a point through
regular season play and then a totally
different place through postseason play
and this year even if they don't win the
title he has gotten to that place
through a dominant dominant postseason
now I what I do think is you know going
into the playoffs I would have said
Giannis is the best player in the league
he lost to Miami so everyone stripped
him of it jokic is the obvious Heir
Apparent if jokic also loses to Miami I
don't know that Giannis should be
penalized because he did because the
order of operations if Miami beats them
both Giannis might retain the crown but
that's because Giannis is a dominant
defensive player and jokic is limited on
that end well I think sometimes well
we're guilty of style points Steph gives
us style points there's guys who give us
style points uh Zion he's excited when
he plays well John he's exciting when he
plays
um what's the result uh with Joker he
doesn't have style points
but he's great I think I think that was
used against Giannis as well though if
you remember we had people arguing
Giannis you know Giannis versus Anthony
Davis was a debate ad1 for a while
Giannis versus Kevin Durant is a debate
Durant in some Corners still wins
because Giannis doesn't have the bag
Giannis doesn't have the quote unquote
skill but up until this year the game
five of that series against Miami
obviously very rough firm at the end his
lack of a jump shot or his hit and miss
free throw shooting had never really
cost him since he had become this fully
realized version of himself my concern
on jokic was in a playoff series when
instead of running your offense you hump
mismatches and you get the worst
defender in a screen and run pick and
roll is he going to be able to hold up
and the answer has been resoundingly yes
he has been an adequate Defender and a
dominant offensive player I can we talk
a bit about the when he scores a bunch
they lose thing
so yeah all right
so I actually think there is a ton of
History backing that up
not involving him necessarily so his
four highest scoring playoff games of
his career they're owing for
do you think it's fair to call jokic a
point Center yes
okay
Isaiah Thomas his the sprained ankle
game is only 40 Point career playoff
game
they lost Isaiah Thomas's five highest
scoring career playoff games losses
Steve Nash's three highest scoring
playoff games losses Stockton's three
highest scoring losses Magic's three
highest scoring losses T there
absolutely is something too when the guy
who gets everyone involved has to take
on the scoring burden it can have
Downstream effects not only on your
offense but what made Isaiah the
original Isaiah so brilliant as he
understood this offensive possession
might not be the most efficient if I go
through Rick Mahorn but I get the best
version of Rick Mahorn if he knows he's
going to be able to touch the ball
occasionally if Michael Porter Jr had
gotten a bunch of clean looks and made
them early in game two I think his
defense would have been better later in
game two sure so I absolutely I know
Spode tried to dismiss it I absolutely
think it is their strategy and it is a
smart strategy of let jokic create 55
points where it is 45 him scoring 10 him
assisting as opposed to 30 25 splits and
I think that's how the Heat win the
title well the heat when the title if
bam out of Bio keeps jokic on us both
ends of the floor
yep because if you look at what uh bam
did guarding him uh last game jokic
scored I think uh field goal percentage
was 46 percent everybody else when they
guarded him it was 77 so he if he keeps
him honest at both ends then they can
win this thing uh well they also with
bam I don't know I'm sure you noticed
you have a very you know refined
basketball eye uh but they had bam doing
some of the point Center stuff bringing
the ball up the court which is an odd
way it's kind of like the offensive
equivalent of when someone guards staff
the moment he brings the ball in it's
like he's okay he's not going to turn
the ball over in the back court but it
wears on him a bit when the guy jokic is
guarding is initiating the offense it
gives him no time to rest even if he's
not going to be out there he's got to be
locked in paying attention and so I the
interesting thing to me is what does
Miami do in the eight minute to game bam
has to sit if he gets in foul trouble
they're cooked they got no chance Zeller
is not playable
they have another seven footer named
Omer York seven he's not gonna play the
other 610 guy is Nikola yovich the
rookie he's not ready
and then they do have a guy your age Dan
Kevin Love no oh no Judy Thomas
dust him off let him get 90. I don't
think he aren't foul he doesn't have to
do it he doesn't have shorts underneath
his uh warm-ups let him do it could you
imagine
UD if the swan song of his career is two
minutes of hard fouls on the league sure
I because you can't play Zeller no you
know I believed at one point the heat
were playing Zeller as a psychological
Ploy against their opponent and maybe
told you this I'm not sure that it's
like all right hey guys we're gonna give
this premature balding white guy with a
mask eight minutes a night just because
it naturally is going to make the other
team take us less seriously and we're
gonna take advantage but then but they
but at this point it's run its course
it's just run its course he's uh Nick
Wright co-host of first things first on
Fox Sports 1 and subscribe to what's
right with Nick Wright on YouTube or
whoever you get your podcast
who do you think leaked the story that
Kyrie was recruiting LeBron
to Dallas oh this is so fascinating
there's so many this is such this is a
really fascinating like piece of
Journalism the Chris Haynes Story the
full Chris Haynes story so now I
understand somehow the in some quarters
they're like oh obviously LeBron did
this or clutch did this I don't see of
the candidates for leaking I don't see
what they had to gain from this but
there are pieces of this that I think
came from all different sources so I
think the Genesis of this report
is Kyrie not because he thinks LeBron is
going to get bought out by the Lakers
and sign with the Mavs for the minimum
because that can't happen and the Mavs
are not going to be able to trade for
LeBron
I think Kyrie wanted this out there
to engender support from the mabs to
give him a Max contract look guys I'm
already recruiting I'm all in you get in
the Kyrie Irving business maybe not this
year but in a future year maybe you're
getting LeBron James business maybe
you're getting a different Superstar
business because no matter what the
media thinks of me being Kyrie other NBA
players like me I'm very popular people
like my game so this is I think Kyrie
trying to look like a good employee
but the other most interesting part of
that story
was in the initial write-up of it Chris
Haynes wrote
the Mavs had discussions prior to the
deadline about trading for LeBron James
that is before the when the Lakers were
floundering that's what was written yeah
I and then others pointed out
um literally ineligible to be traded
because of when he signed his contract
he literally couldn't be traded they
could have offered Luca and 30 first
round picks and the Lakers would have
had to say sorry not allowed Haynes then
added a line to it that said they left
in they had discussion about trading for
LeBron comma despite the fact they were
not able to so that's a weird meeting
it's like hey guys I got an idea trade
for LeBron somebody was like yeah let's
straight for LeBron then somebody in the
back who took you know took Bobby Marx's
CBA courses like um excuse me pardon me
uh not allowed they're like okay good
meeting so
here is what's noteworthy that couldn't
have come from Kyrie because that is
reporting on something that happened
before they even had Kyrie so why was
that in the story here's my hypothesis
the Mavs leaked that part of it to
engender loyalty from Luca look man
we're trying everything where we will do
anything to make this team better up to
and including trying to trade for
players who are not trade eligible we
just want you to be happy so I think
there's a lot of you know kind of
signaling going on through this
reporting But ultimately I think Kyrie
is going to be a MAV on a more expensive
contract than I would pay and LeBron's
going to be a Laker next year yeah but
why don't you leak a trade rumor that
has to do with somebody that you can
actually acquire
yeah I think that was a misstep I gotta
tell you I think that that was like Dame
Lillard hey we're trying to get Dame
Lillard okay there's there's validity to
that
I think it was again I'm speculating
here and maybe this is poor form by me
maybe I shouldn't do this
I think it's because Luca has talked
about that LeBron was his Idol that this
was the player he most looked up to and
LeBron is like the only superstar in the
league
that carries on that carries that level
of weight along with Luca recognizing it
would still be my team because he's so
old you know what I mean like if you say
Dame there are people either like James
better than Luca I think they're wrong
but so I I but the problem was of course
he was not eligible but yeah but here's
the thing with Luca if I'm Luca and they
go oh my God they're trying to get my
idol here and then you realize that your
organization doesn't know that they
can't get LeBron yeah yeah you look
foolish hey I agree I I agree yeah I
was
you know it was said in a reporter's ear
without necessarily thinking it was
going to become one of the major
tentpoles of the story and then have
jerks like me be like literally can't do
it and now you're kind of boxed in again
I'm speculating here I don't know what
happens tonight
the Heat win man
okay the heater the heater gonna win the
title Dan
and your favorite player Reggie Miller
said the heat in six just letting you
know Nick
Reggie Miller
uh so here's an interesting thing and
then I'll get to the game
there are put Reggie and Jimmy's
career side by side regular season
postseason we've talked about it's
really interesting okay so you guys
talked about it my apology yeah yeah but
like the All-Star appearances the all
mbas sure the playoff stuff it is very
similar and I've maybe been a little
harsh on Reggie on this show yes you can
needle you I have listen I've said so
I've said this privately but I'll say it
publicly Reggie is the best 18 3 and 3
guy in league history and I don't even
think it's deniable now to the Miami
you know you're like Stephen hey hey
you're gonna call Joker fat you know tub
of Lorde well that you know that that
reference is dated those eighteen three
and three are etched in stone those
ain't changing buddy he ain't going back
um but compost season you don't want to
mess with Reggie
no listen of course and there's a lot of
legend that comes with having a
legitimate seven game series with Jordan
one of only two guys to do it and having
a legitimate blood Feud was one of
America's greatest filmmakers that you
know I mean those things carry a lot of
weight now and he got into a fight with
Michael Jordan he wasn't afraid of
Michael Jordan no that's what I'm saying
I'm saying okay the the
bait me no I'm not no I'm trying to
prevent you from embarrassing yourself
I'm not embarrassed yes you are yes you
are
I have a lot of respect for the 79th
greatest player in the history of the
NBA a lot
um now if I may resume uh final 30
seconds let's go there is the heater
gonna win the title Dan
and Jimmy Butler is going to be on stage
holding the Larry O'Brien
and the Bill Russell or maybe Bam's
holding the Bill Russell and that's
gonna be the image and the next morning
on Sports television someone's gonna
give a list of top five contenders for
next season and the heat aren't going to
be oh yeah and and it's going to be and
and we're gonna have this this Chiron on
the bottom of our TV shows the Miami
Heat champions comma but were they any
good question mark I mean they there is
nothing this team's gonna be able to do
to gain people's respect up to and
including beating the boxes same with
the Nuggets if the Nuggets win it'll be
Nuggets win title what are the Lakers
chances next year well no but
stand the nuggets are awesome they might
be boring but people know they're
awesome people don't think the heat are
awesome that's that's a different you
you and Michael Malone can complain that
oh I'm sorry where we spend more time
talking about Tom Cruise than Paul
Thomas Anderson like oh but look at the
filmographies give me a break that's
what America is I'm sorry that Keeping
Up with the Kardashians out rates
Downton Abbey but that is society don't
argue with the consumer about what they
want stop that Michael Malone and Dan
Patrick I'm not saying anything other
than you guys fall victim to let's talk
the Cowboys and the Lakers every single
day but and I'm telling you first of all
I haven't talked to Cowboys talked to
them yesterday prior to that I haven't
talked to them in two months
Lakers are interesting the Lakers are
interesting
they were the 13th seed they made the
Conference Finals they have the greatest
player of all time they're interesting
uh what what does Micah Parsons think of
the live tour that's what we're going to
bring up later on today on Thursday okay
you know what what's LeBron what's
LeBron think of uh Jay Monahan as
commissioner moving forward you know
what you know you know okay okay that's
fine all right we all do our own thing I
know everybody I know but you were just
criticizing me because I brought up the
uh nuggets there and you said oh you and
Michael Malone and I call him Mike
uh well you're not supposed to call him
I know but I bet but I do oh you do okay
all right sorry we're like okay have a
great day yeah you too all right that's
first things first that's Nick right
subscribe to what's right with Nick
Wright on YouTube and wherever you get
your podcast
I don't know if we've solved anything
but then we rarely do